hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe auch heute wieder ein leckeres
cache basic video für euch
ich möchte nämlich einen tortenboden
backen und zwar kann man denen dann eben
ganz einfach für motiv torten benutzen
und er ist wirklich sehr viel zeit ich
mag einen hell und dunkel zu bereiten
man kann etwas frucht nur mit
reinbringen und ich zeige jetzt erstmal
so die basis variante also den hellen
tag und später zeige ich euch auch noch
den schoko teig und an zutaten brauchen
wir eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 200 gramm zucker
hier habe ich 200 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und 200 meter
mineralwasser also sprudelndes 300 gramm
in 100 g speisestärke und ein päckchen
backpulver und der teig ist auch sehr
schnell hergestellt
ihr nehmt einfach zuerst die eier und
gebt die in die rührschüssel man kommt
da das salz mit dazu und das vanille
extrakt
und den teig mag ich ganz gerne weil er
sehr luftig locker ist aber eben auch
zeitgleich sehr saftig ist also das
nicht trocken jetzt noch den zucker mit
rein
jetzt wird es erst mal richtig lange
verrührt dass es eine richtig schöne
weiß cremige masse wird
wenn die masse dann so aussieht gebe ich
jetzt noch öl und das wasser mit dazu
und das ist bei niedriger stufe kurz
einrühren und jetzt könnt ihr direkt auf
die trockenen zutaten rein 7
und man kann in diesem tag zum beispiel
auch verschiedene aromen mit einfügen
entweder durch säfte also dann etwas
wasser durchsetzt austauschen durch
likör oder schnäpse
oder man kann zum beispiel auch etwas
zitronenschale oder eben andere aromen
mit einrühren
die trockenen zutaten werden jetzt auch
noch ganz kurz eingeführt bei niedriger
stufe
den fertigen teig fühle ich jetzt in
meine vorbereiteten backformen und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier meine back rahmen
mit backpapier bereits ausgelegt der mit
einem durchmesser von 20 cm und den bug
ich jetzt auch zweimal weil ich gleich
eine torte daraus mache die eben richtig
hoch sein soll
man kann aber diese teilmenge zum
beispiel auch für nutzen für eine 26er
backform und backt daneben den teig auf
einmal
und den kann man sich einfach so hoch
und runter rechnen so wie man eben die
menge benötigt und kann so die backform
daneben ausführen
und so werden sie jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 160 grad bei mir jetzt für
ungefähr 30 bis 35 minuten gebacken
es kommt jetzt einfach drauf an was wenn
der backform ihr benutzt welche größe
gepackt und wie viel teig eingefüllt
habe aber auf jeden fall mache ich
danach die stäbchen probe und zeigt euch
dann den fertigen teig
auf die gleiche art und weise habe ich
jetzt auch einen dom dem teig
hergestellt da habe ich jetzt einen teil
des mehls durch kakaopulver also durch
buck cacau ausgetauscht und schau dir
einfach nach den genauen mengenangaben
auf dem blog vorbei und den könnt ihr
jetzt gerne auch verfeinern zum beispiel
mit kirschen
damit erteilt nämlich noch saftiger und
ich habe einfach ein bisschen frucht mit
dabei
so sehen jetzt die fertigen tortenböden
aus ich habe es ja auch bereits fast
abkühlen lassen und jetzt kann man hier
auch schon die torten rahmen lösen also
beim dunklen habe ich das jetzt schon
gemacht und jetzt auch das weiß die
gleiche teiglinge einmal eben in dieser
zwanziger backform da habe ich jetzt
zwei hohe böden rausbekommen und ein mal
eben der 26er backform darf ich jetzt
zwei flache böden
das heißt wenn ich jetzt bei den großen
böden eine hohe torte möchte muss ich
die menge einfach verdoppeln und einfach
noch mal warten und jetzt lese ich die
noch vom backpapier ab und dann könnt
ihr die anschließend eben für weitere
trocken dekorationen benutzen könnte
befüllen
ihr könnt sie mit marmelade bestreichen
mit ghana spielen mit futter krems
filmen oder mit irgendwie nah sahne
creme film und sie dann später einfach
weiter dekorieren
vor der verwendung lasse ich jetzt
einfach noch komplett abkühlen am besten
ist es sogar wenn er sie dann noch in
frischhaltefolie packt oder zum beispiel
in torten behälter und im kühlschrank
lagert denn einen tag später krümelt sie
dann nicht mehr so sehr
und man kann sie dann auch zum beispiel
super durchschneiden und wenn ihr dieses
rezept nach machen wollt geht einfach
auf meinem blog this - blog.de da habe
ich meine kate basics und da findet ihr
eben die krieg basics zu dem hellen und
zu dem dunklen grundrezept bis zum
nächsten mal